tough guy super cops chasing bad guys
resonates around the world but even the
good guys got to take a break every once
in a while and as the tv season wraps up
et's keeping tabs on four crime fighting
finales to fan out over
you know people who run tend to do it
for a reason blue blood's landmark 12th
season caps off on may 6th following a
major milestone this year the show's
250th episode you know it's i think
hitting a lot of us now because we'll
reminisce a lot at the dinner table
during the dinner scene and we're
starting to like
realize how much time has passed it's
unbelievable and beyond i think anything
that any of us ever imagined
then there's the equalizer it's
sophomore season signs off on may 15th
i'm not gonna handle myself all right
but if you get shot
i'll kill you
as queen latifah tells it she's always
pushing to ramp up the excitement if
anything they gotta hope they have to
hold me back i'm like write more action
write more fun write more intrigue write
more languages i'm always up for the
challenge next up it's time to say aloha
to magnum pi well until next season and
i look forward to that the fourth season
which ends on may 6th saw plenty of
action as well as jay hernandez's
directing debut
i feel like everybody stepped up their
game because they knew i was directing
the episode and wanted it to be good and
wanted to be good for me
and when it comes to exciting television
shamar moore knows a little thing or two
i feel like we're making a movie made
for tv every every week roger that we're
almost there swat closes out season five
on may 22nd and headed into season six
this fall chamar tells e.t he's up for
anything well almost anything hondo's
not scared of nothing okay but shimar
don't like heights all right and so
they're hanging me off of helicopters
and i got to rappel off buildings i do
it i do it but i tell the stunt team i
said you got to give me about 30 minutes
to like get the yayas out like you got
you got to prove to me this cable is
going to hold me like you know me
[Music]